okay I I want to do this but I want to
do it not about me I want to do it about
the progressive movement because this is
really concerning to me as many of you
know every once a year or every six
months or something I will show you some
of what I consider to be the weirdest or
most unusual or most capricious
cancellation messages from people for
example someone cancelled their
membership once because I said on the
bonus show I don't really think Ford
cars are that great someone canceled
because they really liked Ford cars
another case someone said that they were
canceling their membership because I
attacked the people of Iowa when I said
I don't think the primary process should
start with Iowa nor should it start with
a caucus some people interpret it one
person interpreted that as me attacking
Iowans those are stories that are kind
of like about the David Pakman show this
cancellation story is about the
progressive movement and the left in
general it's a really insidious
problematic one I got an email from
someone responding to their membership
cancellation message by saying simply
not a fan of the fans of Bernie Sanders
clearly saying I am canceling my
membership because I don't like people
like you who like Bernie Sanders now you
all know I am NOT a Bernie or bust
person and in fact I'm criticized for
that I have said before if the nominee
is Biden I will vote for Biden and here
are 10 ways in which Biden is better
than Trump if the nominee were to be
Bloomberg I would vote for Bloomberg and
here are it's a shorter list but here
are like three or four reasons why
Bloomberg is better than Trump I am NOT
a Bernie or bust person but I do like
Bernie Sanders and I've said that in
Massachusetts here I will support him so
when someone says I'm canceling support
because I'm not a fan of the fans of
Bernie Sanders it's not because I've
said anything that I consider to be
destructive like Bernie or bust Bernie
or I'm staying home Bernie or I'm voting
Trump I would never do that and I think
it's self-destructive this is merely a
not participate you know there's this
idea the Bernie bros are mean I don't
believe the supporters of any anybody
other than Trump supporters I tell them
I think you guys are out of your mind
but when it comes to the Democratic
primary I've not done that I am very
concerned with this type of thing
because of what it does signal about the
movement more broadly because if you
don't prioritize the removal of the
worst person as the top priority and
instead say things like if you are
merely a fan of Bernie Sanders I don't
like you I don't believe your show is
worthy of support what are you doing at
the ballot box what are you doing in
your community in regards to being an
activist and influencing the politics
around you I think this is completely
and totally self-destructive it's
extraordinarily concerning of course I'm
sorry to lose the membership but I'm
more sorry about the fact that this type
of thinking exists in my audience at all
and I know that it does this isn't the
only person a lot of the people aren't
members who a lot of people just don't
have memberships to cancel but I'm
worried about this and as we start to
see the further primary results come in
this is the type of ideology that I
believe will have one effect which is
increasing the probability that Donald
Trump is re-elected to a second term let
me know if you disagree with me